let's see who is calling today from the
nine one six area code 906 of the area
hey John hey so I got a couple of
questions it's in the realm of taxes
sure you know recently with the Trump
great tax reform me and my wife we
really got hit hard here in California
because of salt deduction went away a
lot of that had to do with our employer
not withholding enough and I was
wondering do you believe there be any
recourse because employers I'm hearing
from a lot of my colleagues and friends
that they've all got hit with five
$10,000 tax bills and these are just
kind of average to middle-class people
so you're saying there let me see if I
understand John though I want to make
sure so I'll explain the salt limit in a
second to people but you're saying
people who just work all of their income
is w2 income they work for an employer
and that it's all w2 income and they are
having to cut a check for ten grand when
they file their taxes only on the basis
of how their withholdings changed as a
result of the or didn't change arguably
because of the Trump tax plan that's
correct so if you look you fast forward
a couple years ago no Trump no tax
reform people are getting thousand
dollars back yep they're back to putting
ones or twos on their w2 I think it is
yeah that's word to today you know I had
to go to a CPA and immediately pull
receipts out really dig and really try
and find a way to get above that twenty
four thousand because all of a sudden me
and my wife had a five thousand dollar
tax burden out of nowhere so I was that
water that sounds like I mean so you're
talking about a six thousand dollar
swing in terms of getting a thousand
back versus paying paying five thousand
and how much did the deduction that
withholdings during the year change
relative to that six thousand did you
have two thousand less withheld or four
thousand less withheld um it was I don't
have the exact numbers between your one
year to like what change by no it was
they haven't been pretty drastic like
they did not withhold 5,000 additional
so my paycheck went up a little bit and
I felt like that's great maybe that's
what the tax reform was supposed to do
it was made more in my paycheck yep but
then obviously I have this bill so I
wonder this in the numbers aren't adding
opportu me I I don't so listen I don't
think you have any recourse it's it's
sort of in some way it is your
responsibility to tell your employer how
much they just withhold what you tell
them you could maybe argue as a courtesy
they should have said listen everybody
should should review their withholdings
or something like that I don't think you
have recourse the numbers aren't really
making sense to me when when you mention
them I'm not saying I don't believe you
what I I'm wondering if there's
something else that explains the drastic
change what really matters in the end is
your actual effective tax rate and we
won't know that until until you finish
filing or maybe you already do you know
what your actual change in tax rate was
it was favorable but the licenses but
you just ended up having that cut a
check at the end of the year yes I did
so it's not bad your song is impossible
John unfortunately I don't know how what
you're saying is possible because if
you're saying that you ended up having
to cut a check for five grand but you
did not have an additional five thousand
withheld but also your effective tax
rate went down I don't know how all of
those things can be true well here's how
it's true your monthly payment because
what taxes the tax reform did was say
let's try and fix the problem with
deduction so we get the refunds closer
to zero it was what comp theory was in
my mind okay and so he had more going to
my paycheck so say my paycheck went out
three hundred four hundred five hundred
dollars a month whatever whatever then
did that be effectively they weren't
withholding it enough and they were
they're playing a shell game and my
money was going to my paycheck it looks
like things are going to wow the
Republicans are doing great things for
me my paycheck went up with them but
ultimately they just moved the money
around because they weren't was holding
a lot and so I get that but what's not
making sense John is and that we don't
have to go through your full tax return
what's not me I understand the concept
of moving the money around so you get an
extra three hundred but then you owe
you know that three 300 times twelve
months would be like 3,600 but you're
simultaneously saying that the amount
you owe is more than the withholdings
increase but that your tax rate actually
went down and that just that just
doesn't add up but I'm not sure John I
will I will continue to look into it and
I appreciate the phone call there's
probably some piece of information there
that's that's missing